marvel vs capcom infinite is happening  but capcom might not stop there i'm tony  and this is your revived gamespot news  update in a news release the company  stated that it will focus on reviving  quote dormant franchises capcom didn't  name any title specifically but it's  worth noting that infinite is the first  game in the marvel vs capcom series in  five years for reference we haven't seen  a new beautiful Joe game since 2005 or  in original darkstalkers since 1998 so  those are certainly dormant franchises  too we'll see what happens marvel vs  capcom infinite is slated for a 20-17  release on ps4 xbox one and pc so far  we've seen six characters confirmed for  the roster so expect plenty more to be  revealed in the coming months in the  meantime you can always dig into the  re-release of Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom  3 on ps4 to keep up with all the latest  on Capcom's many franchises you're  already in the right place